hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to right-click - necromancy
now I'm not under censure about this but
I'm pretty sure that this has nothing to
do with that dance of the necromancer
game trip to the necromancer
necromancing crypto dancer necro crypto
dancing pants right-click - neck romance
either way this was made for a game jam
sometime last year and it involves ooh
hello hi oh hi hello everybody my name
is markiplier I'm here to kill you hey
you want to fight oh [ __ ]
oh damn it they're so cute whoa that's
awesome necromancy way wait I just need
to kill people and then they come back
oh [ __ ] that's not good ah oh no I died
well what was I supposed to do I mean
obviously not suck and deal with a snis
deal Ivan it's not suck and be total ass
ok so I gotta go through the small
groups first hey Hayley this is it
boink ok so once you get the small
groups dead you can get more yeah ok
come here you hey yeah I like this it's
like exponential growth Hey
hey buddies hey friend you're all alone
that's a mistake habit I can a
necromancer
what a neck remise oh hey ok you want to
fight oh boy this is a lot of people
more people than I anticipated
ah they're coming after me No
dammit god dammit it's harder than I
thought it'd be I mean I didn't know
what anything it would be so I didn't
think anything going into this hey go
get you hey you got us ok get these guys
alright well we got a lot of competition
over here can stop killing my dudes
I need more dudes oh let's avoid them ok
so the field ain't too big so I just
need to not let them conglomerating hey
oh hey hey hey whoa hey buddy you are
big I did not know you were there
can I eventually necromancer that guy
you get these guys get him up
get up kill them kill them kill them
dead okay you you group of four I can
take you you think your tooth you think
your tooth oh geez group of five coming
in but so long as I get the four I'll be
fine
yes yes yes yes yes okay now we got a
big army going on here a big girthy army
hey you want to join my army nothing you
have much of a choice
also wire random soldiers just staying
around in a random field somewhere in a
random place okay your dad oh you're
dead all of you is gonna be dead yep you
cannot withstand my girth join my girthy
nature are you group of seven huh too
bad you're still gonna die we've got
them surrounded dead all right you all
of you everybody come on in the water's
warm inside my pie oh geez oh god that's
not good
well alright big fight ah we're gonna
win we're gonna win we're gonna win
we're gonna win it heavy losses but
we're gonna win nonetheless giddy hatee
hatee hatee hatee hey yatta Hooda and
you're all dead yes I don't know if we
gained anymore or lost everybody well
they're bigger let's not go over the
bigger ones just yet how about a habit
to have it happen this game's cool I
actually like it whoo there we go
habitat whoo buddy see you whoop there
we go
are you stuck on a rock over there
you're trying to hide behind it well you
can't escape your fate
so wait where's your buddy there's a
rusty yet all righty then
got them hello before I fight the big
guys I want to pick on the little guys
cuz that's what markiplier does he
exploits people's weaknesses if you can
even call it a weakness just cheer
outnumbering him hey your boy scary
scary scary scary okay you know what
oh they're coming they're all right
let's do this ah oh god that's not gonna
work is it ah they're too strong
No No get him kill him oh Jesus is not
what we're looking for kill the big guys
first if you can if you can't you know
what good effort team good hustle out
there you didn't you didn't do what you
were supposed to do but you tried and
that's all that matter
[ __ ] you guys you guys suck I thought
the last minute encouragement would have
been enough to make you not be
a bag of dicks is actually pretty clever
like I've never seen a game like this
it's it's just kind of a unique style of
game that I haven't experienced before
but it's pretty cool I gotta admit that
they're doing dirt they're doing a
pretty good job here this is pretty good
for being a jam game it's really good
it's simple concepts like this that just
make a game fun because that's what a
game should be should be some sort of
fun I would one would hope get him get
him get them all up spliffs okay got you
it's like a virus spreading around but a
virus being random people on a
battlefield and I'm assuming I'm zombies
we're a necromancer so we're raising
people from the dead so I it would be
under the assumption that everybody here
is perfectly justified in their
attempting wanton murder of us because
we're horrible creatures from beyond the
group we're literally their friends that
have come back from the dead and not in
the good way in the horrible oh my god
you're a zombie way your soul has been
possessed the Lich King is attempting to
absorb your power that kind of thing
they're trying to hide you can't hide
from me
you can't run away alright so I'm
getting big enough I'm getting goofy
enough hopefully some bigger packs are
gonna come by give me plenty of soldiers
yes thank you yes thank you please don't
resist thank you your efforts are futile
you shall be assimilated okay there's a
big crew over there I don't know if I'm
girthy enough to beat them oh they're
coming
alright well time to test it I think I'm
I think I'm gonna win this one easy how
did you turn dheere dheere dheere dheere
dheere dheere dheere today didn't it oh
that's not good though okay no no no no
get back get back
run run okay they're gonna stay there
okay they're run away alright that's
good you know that's good got him nailed
him
alright so I got a big crew here but
what I got to do is I got a not be
swarmin did you want to whoop they were
gunning for it they were gunning for it
bad okay they're coming over here Ron
Ron Ron retreat okay stop retreating
press onward form the shape of a dick
they get they're gonna come down here so
if I could know those five are gonna
freak
me up dude they're gonna mess me the F
okay there's a big crew but they're
followed by three big dudes oh hello
hello ammo yes what's with the big ol
wizard dude I'm not ready to fight that
guy whoa whoa whoa whoa run I'll take
you yes please join my army join my crew
I'll take you okay goodbye yeah
hello ah it's too many yeah I need this
group whoa
just gone ah no too big
run away run okay good thing they give
up really easily okay so that's a tactic
that you need to do you need to actually
run away from these people okay this
group is gonna be mine assimilate
assimilate assimilate okay got them all
right I'm not gonna I'm not gonna tango
with the big guy they're stuck on a rock
but that's good enough for me to rock
them oh that ain't good
nothing good okay nope not joining that
Frank get out get out bail bail bail
okay
Christian Bale oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] dude oh
no oh no dude ye there's some dead
people there but I haven't killed the
whole crew there are so many people
there so I'm gonna simulate this group
here you're mine don't join the fray do
not do not join this thank you oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
okay yes okay get them yeah okay somehow
no my buddies where did you come from
you know what we're going for it ah
Frick this is the end of me oh god get
that skip that crew get that crew get
that crew yes
oh we're fighting on two fronts here why
No get these guys I want you in my army
yes we got big guys okay we got big guys
we got some big guys which is gonna help
us because now I can take on new
apparently not ooh not that guy this is
so much more difficult than I thought
it'd be all right you know what I'm
going for you guys I don't know how
tough this gonna be gonna be pretty
tough ain't it how they did it how did
it it didn't give me one of you I want
you I why
you in my group can you everyone please
there we go yes I don't know who those
guys are bigger okay so we're doing okay
we're doing okay nope not them not them
I'm picky I'm picky there's a lot more
strategy to this than I thought they'd
be cuz they are not very forgiving when
you don't have the right people in bound
ok got them away this this big guy does
help let me try to get this group yes
yeah yeah yes yes and yes okay good good
good we're doing much better much better
than we were doing can even take this
big group on if I've woo not that guy
why are small guys still here or I'm
gonna swarm them get them get them down
get around him get around him get around
him get that guy down woah that's that's
too many peeps that's a lot of peeps oh
no oh no oh no those big guys there
they're too tough oh god oh no oh no oh
no nothing oh boy
all right you know what okay well this
did not go according to plan all right
can I take these guys on one guy take
down all these dudes we eventually cycle
down to something a bit more manageable
for me to do alright well he died
alright that sucked but it's getting
better it's not good but it's getting
better I think I think the problem is
like I need to encircle people but it's
kind of hard to do that get him get him
gaudy the advantage versus the big guys
is that you can you you can have a whole
bunch of people whaling on them at once
and they can only hit one at a time
circle spread out fan out nice okay this
is going better this is going a lot
better than it was circle around circle
around and closing kill um slaughter
them okay here we go big crew alright go
it around him around him around him yeah
I was afraid of these big guys but I
really shouldn't have been get got big
guys in the crew now okay good we're
doing way better than we were like way
better infinitely better right you want
it you want some of this well good thing
we are all about
surround and pound come on get him come
on guys do better than this come on guys
come on guys oh come on
yes okay got big guys in the crew what
you gonna do dig up them oh god no oh
god no oh God this is not what we
intended but okay it's what we got okay
there we go got him okay
got those guys oh this is just very
stressful here we go big army oh that's
actually really cool the like skull face
guys they split them up so that there's
more space them out so we can surround
them easier I'm all about surrounding
them I guess the eventual goal is to be
able to to kill the the big guy in the
bottom-left may be I have no idea if
that's actually the goal but that's
actually creepy if that is yeah those
guys overwhelming numbers okay you you
guys are coming with me I don't care if
you are the bigger versions of them
you're getting surrounded and you're
getting murdered come here you come here
you come here you I still got some
little guys in my crew
I've gotta help oh no you're gonna die I
think we're pretty much getting
unstoppable here we've reached a girthy
size which is only going to be the best
oh hello
mini guy oh [ __ ] dude [ __ ] [ __ ] dude
dead alright so we got it we got a mini
dude in our way which is helpful
question mark I think so
nice dice okay I'm gonna go for the guy
oh wait no I'm not I'm gonna get these
guys first
no don't dip wizard man don't be in
front whoa hello big Cruz oh my god well
maybe yeah good thing I I didn't do it
too soon cuz holy [ __ ]
oh my god we're being attacked from all
sides here we got to get these guys in
yes big crew spellcasters still
protected okay good okay I think I think
we're we're probably pretty good here
we're probably doing just fine wait
where's the rest of your crew was that
guy part of it down there okay good all
right get these guys and then we're good
all right so we're gonna avoid these
guys and we're just gonna go for this
let's do this let's do this let's do
this he can't be that tough how tough
could he be whoa okay then spellcasters
do not get up all up in his grill that
that is the opposite no that's that's
not what we needed
come on how tough can he be yay oh he's
okay he's part of my crew now when will
it end
when will the bloodshed end I guess when
I'm gonna push it see how far this
[ __ ] goes then holy [ __ ] we're
getting uh there's a lot there's a lot
of people here there's a lot of people
Oh
hello welcome back okay like I just need
to wait in the middle and just let
people come to me because I'm I don't
think anyone can actually beat me hello
oh this is the biggest group that I've
seen but I still don't think it's gonna
be enough oh they're coming for me oh
they're all coming for me come on show
me what you got
don't be so good okay I think that's
pretty much it I don't think there's
anything else to do because I've been
doing this for a while and doesn't seem
like there's a new creatures but for a
game jam game it's an interesting
concept Iroh hey hello big guy welcome
to the party I guess you're here now
maybe there isn't end of the game but
either way if there is an end I don't
have the patience to get to it because
I've been playing this for a while now
and I don't know what it's gonna be over
and I seem to be losing a lot of bee
up never never mind there there more
people so in a way you can play this for
yourself too the link in the description
below I'm pretty sure this game is free
it's fun and hey the developer should
improve on this concept because it's an
interesting idea and there's a lot of
potential here so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought down the comments below and let
me know if you play it and there's
anything beyond what we see right now so
thanks again everybody and as always I
will see you in the next video actually
I just thought of it a multiplayer
version of this game would be so much
fun like it's kind of like agario and
the concept that you just go grow bigger
from taking from other people but the
concept is there and this is this could
be really cool in a multiplayer game so
we doing yeah that's all I want to say
[Music]